joined now by the shadow of justice
secretary steve reed for some more on
this steve uh good morning to you first
of all
let's just pick up if we can on those
price rises i mean we've seen some ideas
coming in as how to deal with it do you
support this idea of just not bringing
that price right in when the new price
cap is made on the 26th of october
sorry labour's going to bring forward a
full package of proposals in the next
few days so we'll see entirely what our
package will be but the point is we've
got a zombie government that's gone slow
at every single stage of this growing
crisis over the last over the last year
labour proposed a windfall tax on the
surplus profits of the energy companies
nearly a year ago initially the
government said they would never do that
and then the u-turned but they haven't
done that properly because it turns out
there's a great big loophole in the
middle of it and for every pound that
the energy companies are investing they
get a 91p subsidy back from the taxpayer
now that is money and it will amount to
billions of pounds that is money that
could be being used to help families who
are right now facing seeing their energy
bills rocket
uh and to an eye-watering extent from
about a thousand pounds on average a
year ago we just saw the figures that
you put up on the screen there the
projection for next april is that they
will hit four and a half thousand pounds
on average now millions of families are
desperately worried that they will be
going into debt just to pay their energy
bills over this winter and instead of
doing anything to help this government
is uh they've got soon i can trust
fighting each other like rats in a sack
and the government doing absolutely
nothing about coming up with proposals
for how they can help people face this
crisis which is looming and terrifying
families families are already in debt
because of the bills that that they're
facing and you say that the labour party
is going to come forward with some
proposals in the next few days i've been
asking a week for you guys to come
forward with proposals but gordon brown
seems to i mean he's is he the leader
for the period while securities
it's always interesting to hear what
gordon brown has got to say he's a very
senior
figure from you know his former labour
former labour prime minister as i said
leading your policy right now this is
when we're going through this crisis
well we'll see our policy over the next
few days that'll be brought out in in
full the the key problem here is that
we've got a government that seems to be
like a zombie government it's time they
got off up this off the slab and started
focusing on what they can do to help the
british people right now but instead of
that labor will be coming up with our
proposals next week trust and sunnac are
saying they're going to do nothing not
even look at it until september what is
the point of having a government if
they're not going to help through a
crisis like this
well look the point being made by gordon
brown is that crisis don't take holidays
secure starman is on holiday and he's
the one who's leading the charge for the
labour party right now no labour's going
to come come up with a fully costed
package of proposals for how we will
help british people within the next few
days next week is when we'll bring that
forward the government the government
are meeting the you know the
chancellor's meeting the energy
companies today and bizarrely they've
been trailing that they're not going to
take any decisions from that meeting one
of the things they could do is to close
that tax loophole and instead of
subsidizing energy companies that are
making so much money they don't know
what to do with it use that money to
give help to the british people now
steve did you write you know that
loophole as you call it is they say it's
to make sure that these companies keep
investing and we'll we don't need to
it's nothing of the sort is it because
their investment decisions decisions are
taken years in advance so all they're
doing is subsidizing them for decisions
they took years ago that money should be
helping british people if your your
energy bill is going to go up from a
thousand pounds to four and a half
thousand pounds in six months how on
earth are people going to pay that
you're looking at nearly a third of the
british people going into debt because
of this we need the government to focus
on this problem not watch soon i can
trust fight each other likes rats in a
sack when we should be having a
government that's focused on the
problems of the british people so the
labor party is going to come with a
package of proposal would one of them be
to renationalize these companies if the
price keeps rising that is that i mean
that's something that um rachel reeves
and kierstarma have both said we're not
looking at at the moment i mean if
there's a if there is money available
then we need to be using it to help
british people right now nationalizing
companies costs an awful lot of money
i'd rather that we're looking at what we
can do to help british people and we
have to do that responsibly within the
funding that that is available there
will as i say be a full package brought
forward in the next few days you'll hear
more about it um over the weekend i'm
sure you'll have me or my colleagues on
the show i hope so talk about it but
what you won't have is anyone from the
government saying what they're going to
do because they intend to sit on their
hands for another month i've already
given the government just time about
this and i will continue to do that
throughout the day if i can let's move
on to strike action now the labour party
of course have in a difficult position
when it comes to strikes there's the
a strike from postal workers we've got a
barrister strike ongoing at the moment
where do you stand on the british
striker shadow justice secretary would
you join them on the pickup well i don't
i don't see why you say the labour party
is in a difficult position on the
strikes because because i think a lot of
unions who are backing the strikes who
have balloted their members would like
to see the labour party full-throatedly
backing the workers and fighting for
them to get i'm a former trade union
shop steward uh myself um the role of a
trade union is to get out there and to
fight for their workers including on the
picket line when their workers choose to
go on strike the labour party is now
preparing to enter government it is not
our job to stop the british people going
to work it is our job to demonstrate
that we fully understand the immense
pressures that this tor regenerated cost
of living crisis is putting on household
budgets and demonstrate what we can do
to help now in terms of the strikes
themselves i've been absolutely
astonished that the government has just
sat back and refused to get involved and
to try and help negotiate a solution to
the problems whether it's the trains
whether it's the barristers time and
time again they just step back nothing
to do with me gov you know what's the
point of having a government if they're
not going to help with the energy crisis
and they're not going to help with the
cost of living crisis if they're not
going to help resolve the strikes that
are happening frankly because the
government has allowed this um cost of
living crisis to spiral out of control
it's the government that needs to be
doing things uh right now labour will be
demonstrating next week that we have the
ideas and the plan to help the british
people while the government is doing
absolutely diddly squat right steve read
shadow justice actually look forward to
hearing those ideas next week you said
absolutely next few days next week
all right thank you very much